ted as we can see is out in the field
tonight he is at the smith's location in
sky canyon because we're kicking off our
great food drive as we've done every
year here hi there ted
hey denise brian yes it started on
monday and of course goes all the way to
december
4th and of course i'm live because we're
trying to entice people to come on down
your local schmitz grab
you'll see these boxes at the front of
the store it's the great food drive you
can't miss it and as people have done a
great job doing
it's at project 150 we actually partner
up with smith's and we help out project
150 every year with good reason here to
tell us more about it is our good friend
kelly cristo with project 150 tell us
about uh about the organization so the
organization helps homeless displaced
and disadvantaged high school students
stay in school so we provide the basic
necessities like food school supplies
hygiene products year round to make sure
that we take care of all their barriers
so they continue to go to school and
like we talked about it's hard for these
teenagers already now they this is what
they need to help them
succeed in life this is just one sliver
of the pie so this part is so great
because we partner with you guys and
smith and we collect all the
non-perishable food items and then we
deliver them to the schools every week
all 75 local high schools that is
awesome now last year we were hit hard
by copenhagen how bad was it for you
guys last year oh it was awful last year
i mean we saw numbers triple four times
something like that what we do for food
distribution so hopefully it's gonna
plum down a little bit this season but
um this is really going to help because
when we distribute this food this
removes one small barrier in the
household and we're happy to help we're
happy to help kelly and and we're asking
the viewers we're asking you guys to
please you're going to go shopping
anyways
right hello smith so grab some
non-perishable food items throw them in
your cart check out and go drop them off
in the front of the store i'm at sky
canyon but this is at all smith's
locations let's help out those teenagers
it's tough for them already to be in
school let's give them something to eat
let's help them concentrate in school
and succeed